l'armée américaine interdit au panama
elle tente de capturer noriega sans
succès pour l'instant il ya une
cinquantaine de morts
la répression en roumanie peut être
plusieurs milliers de victimes pour chat
ou sescousse c'est simplement que
l'armée a répondu au roulis gagnent
situation bloquée dans le groupe i des
nmpp
les patrons de presse mobilisent pour
distribuer les journaux ou d'une autre
manière
boris godounov un signe un film avec
ruggero raimondi une vision personnelle
du film opéra signé andré d'où la sq
bonsoir
l'armée américaine est intervenue au
panama le dictateur noriega n'est plus
au pouvoir
il est en fuite mais les américains ne
l'ont pas capturé ce qu'ils n'offensent
yves audacieuse car lancé le président
george bush depuis trois ans il tentait
de mettre fin aux agissements du
dictateur considéré aussi comme un
trafiquant de drogue mais 20 dictateur
soutenu par une partie de la population
du panama une partie de son peuple qui
ne souhaitent pas être colonisée par les
amériques la sphère été difficile george
bush a foncé récit de cette opération
éclair qui s'éternise et qui a tout de
même fait une cinquantaine de victimes
michel mompontet il n'ya que 56 minutes
george bush donné son feu vert et déjà
le quartier général de l'armée
panaméenne est en flammes
les stratèges américains sont alors
persuadé que noriega est réfugié dans
cette caserne
les à tort pendant ce temps de très
violents combats font rage dans toute la
ville au petit matin les premiers bilans
circulent
on parle alors de 52 60 morts dont de
nombreux civils blindés hélicoptères
troupes d'élite
visiblement les etats-unis ont décidé de
frapper fort
vite des combats éclatent dans plusieurs
autres villes du pays entre ces hommes
de troupe et l'armée du général noriega
la confusion est alors totale les
américains semblent parfaitement
contrôlé le ciel les avoir des
difficultés au sol face à de nombreuses
poches de résistance toutes les casernes
des pistes d'aéroport sans
systématiquement bombardé par l'us air
force des célèbre béret vert héros du
vietnam
on entre en action les renforts ne
cessent d'arriver troupes spécialisées
18 heures après le déclenchement de la
tacc les 9000 hommes de troupes
américains semblent contrôler la
situation
le quartier général panaméen détruit des
casernes abandonnées
la télé la radio sous contrôle mais
l'objectif numéro un des américains
n'est toujours pas ce soir atteint
noriega s'est enfui pour le duo costa
rica ou dans la jungle panaméenne en
tout cas il semble encore loin des
tribunaux américains george bush le
président américain s'est expliqué à la
télévision tout à l'heure pour lui
l'intervention devenait obligatoire au
panama puisque toutes les autres
solutions notamment les solutions
négociées avait échoué patricia cost
grave les traits tirés à la suite d'une
nuit blanche la voix voilée par une
laryngite
le président bush s'est adressé ce matin
à son pays chers concitoyens j'ai
ordonné aux forces militaires
américaines de se déployer au panama
aucun président ne prend une telle
mesure à la légère et le président bush
de justifier l'intervention américaine
en affirmant que toutes les options
diplomatiques avaient échoué
george bush ajoute les menaces et
attaques constantes du général noriega
contre des américains au panama ont créé
un danger imminent pour les 35 mille
citoyens américains vivant au panama
et c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé à nos
forces armées de protéger la vie des
citoyens américains présents au panama
et de déférer le général noriega devant
la justice des états unis qui l'a
inculpé de trafic de stupéfiants en 1988
l'opération militaire a fait remarquer
ce matin monsieur bush n'est pas encore
terminée même si les objectifs
militaires clés ont été atteints et que
l'essentiel de la résistance organisée a
été matée sur le plan institutionnel
l'opération qui avait pour but de
rétablir le processus démocratique a
permis à des dirigeants élus en vertu de
la constitution de prendre le pouvoir
selon monsieur bush en l'occurrence il
s'agit de guillermo endara le chef de
l'opposition vainqueur
les élections de mai dernier annulée par
le général noriega le panama c'est un
sujet qui démangent les américains
depuis plusieurs années il contrôle le
canal mais ils doivent le rendre
en tout cas ils entendent bien rester
maîtres de la région face aux états unis
un dictateur qui s'appuie sur son peuple
sur une partie de son peuple en tout cas
mais qui a de bien mauvaise manière
notamment côté trafic de drogue
jean-marc il use portrait en armes dont
la mémoire de millions d'américains le
régime noriega c'est d'abord cela des
sbires du général qui sans même se
cacher des caméras corrige un civil
désarmé
c'était en mai dernier l'homme à la
chemise ensanglantée était guillermou
ford l'un des trois candidats de
l'opposition dont l'équipe venait de
remporter les élections haut la main
avertissement suivi de l'annulation pure
et simple du scrutin
le général noriega avait imposé le
candidat de son choix à deux millions de
panat mer un énorme pied de nez à
washington mais manuel antonio noriega
militaire de carrière n'est plus depuis
longtemps le serviteur fidèle de la cia
quinze mois plus tôt une inculpation aux
états unis pour trafic de drogue a fait
de lui la bête noire des américains à
washington
les réactions outragées du président
bush ne suffisent pas à calmer au
congrès ceux qui veulent en finir je
cite avec le petit dictateur
george bush choisit d'abord la
modération
un mélange de pression économique de
mouvements de troupes avec tentatives de
négociation via les pays latino
américains mais sans succès en coulisses
l'amérique pouces une opposition
légitime mais incapables de mobiliser et
simultanément tentent d'exploiter le
mécontentement dans l'armée panaméenne
nouvel échec deux tentatives de coups
d'état sont écrasés par le général
noriega à chaque fois washington ne
saura ne pourra ou ne voudra intervenir
d'abord par crainte de relance et
l'antiaméricanisme dans la région
pourtant douze mille soldats américains
sont basés le plus légalement du monde
sur le canal de panama
un canal qui n'a plus l'importance
stratégique et commercial d'avant la
seconde guerre mondiale mais où
l'amérique ne peut se permettre de
perdre indéfiniment la face vendredi
dernier nouveau coup les théâtres
noriega se fait nommer chef du
gouvernement par son parlement et
déclare l'état de guerre avec les états
unis
la tension remonte deux incidents
opposent militaire panaméen et
américains un lieutenant des marines est
abattu pour le président bush la mesure
est pleine
noriega ça suffit d'une dictature
l'autre la roumanie maintenant c'est le
mauvais exemple des démocraties
populaires tout change pas elle
il y à quelques minutes le dictateur
ceausescu le danube de la pensée comme
il se fait appeler a reconnu que l'armée
était bien intervenu à timisoara mais
pour lui ce n'était que des hooligans ce
qui avait semé la violence
en fait la répression face aux
manifestants a été d'une violence inouïe
hier on parlait de 300 à 400 morts selon
certaines sources pour nous aujourd'hui
par l' agence de presse adn le bilan
serait plutôt de 3000 ou 4000 morts
et ce soir on a appris que deux
nouvelles manifestations avaient lieu à
timisoara
cinquante mille personnes selon
certaines sources manifesterait jérôme
baugnies dernier témoignage
d'abord décrit habache a hoché ce coup
puis à l'adresse des soldats qui
s'approche on avoue cochons ils viennent
vernon clame quelqu'un éclate alors les
premiers coups de feu la fusillade
s'amplifie mitrailleuses lourdes et
enfin les chars sur ce document sonore
l'ampleur de la répression contre les
manifestants de timisoara le 17 décembre
ce soir à la télévision roumaine nicolas
ceausescu l'a d'ailleurs reconnu les
unités militaires ont été obligés de
défendre l'ordre et les institutions dit
il les événements de timisoara sont très
graves
il faut maintenant rechercher les
auteurs de ces troubles il s'agit de
hooligans de terroristes fascistes
manipulés par des services secrets
étrangers précise monsieur schaus et
secouent la capitale budapest est
quadrillée par la police et l'armée
la plupart des grandes villes du pays en
état de siège mais la télévision
roumaine garde le silence sur ces
événements et diffuse ce reportage le
voyage de ceausescu à téhéran
le dictateur marxiste léniniste et actés
s'inclinant sur la tombe du musulman
khomeiny au même moment toujours à
timisoara
de nouvelles manifestations dégénèrent
et tourne à l'affrontement
alors que l'on apprend que tous les
étudiants de la ville aurait été déporté
à part la chine à l'ouest comme à l'est
la condamnation a été unanime de ski
source les événements de roumanie ce
matin jean paul ii a condamné lui aussi
la répression compte dans ce pays tout à
l'heure le premier ministre michel
rocard à exprimer l'horreur et la
consternation de la france c'était à
l'assemblée en réponse à une question
d'un député à propos des relations
diplomatiques entre la france et la
roumanie
écoutez vous avez monsieur le député a
évoqué l'idée de la rupture des
relations diplomatiques
à cela je ne répondrai qu'une chose nous
avons des citoyens français présents
dans ce pays
mon interrogation par rapport à votre
question monsieur le député à partir du
moment où nous avons la même réflexion
de fond là dessus n'est que sur la
capacité de protection que l'autorité
internationale de la france permet via
ses ambassades de donner un certain
nombre de personnes physiques menacés
dans leurs droits
nous sommes la représentation nationale
unanime sûrement la france entière
solidaires du peuple roumain opprimés le
régime de ceausescu ne pourra pas très
longtemps bafouée l'ensemble de l'europe
et les droits des gens les plus
élémentaires
nous ne pouvons monsieur le député être
certain que d'une seule chose mais elle
est essentielle sort réservé à cette
dictature sera fatalement celui qui
attend tous les régimes funeste de ce
type il tombera et le plus tôt sera le
mieux en france condamnation de tous
côtés de cette dictature roumaine et à
l'assemblée nationale tout à l'heure les
députés ont observé une minute de
silence en hommage aux victimes de la
répression aveugle du dictateur
ceausescu est encore une réaction
le parti communiste yougoslave a rompu
ses relations avec le pc romain françois
mitterrand en allemagne de l'est le
président vient d'arriver il ya quelques
minutes à berlin est
le voici qui arrive donc à berlin trois
jours de visite officielle pour le
président français qui fera accompagner
qui est accompagné d'un mitterrand pour
ce trois jours pour s'entretenir avec
les nouveaux dirigeants de rda et
notamment avec le premier ministre
en mode raw deux thèmes majeurs pour
cette visite officielle les nouveaux
rapports entre la france l'europe et les
pays de l'est mais aussi deuxième thème
l'éventuelle réunification de
l'allemagne
philippe rochot à berlin ce drapeau de
l'unité allemande slogan pour ou contre
la réunification nous sommes le peuple
une allemagne pour l'europe si slogan
françois mitterrand les entendra tout au
long de son voyage en rda de berlin est
à leipzig lighting la cité de la
contestation temps forts de son voyage
la ville aux quinze mille étudiants
la cité où l'église évangélique joue un
rôle militant et orchestre les
manifestations qui voit chaque lundi sur
cette place des filets deux cent à trois
cent mille personnes
derrière ce mouvement de leipzig
particulièrement disciplinés il y à un
homme courte masur chef d'orchestre
dirigeante un palais de la musique le
gewandhaus françois mitterrand le
rencontrera il se veut rassurant sur le
problème de la réunification allemande
les peuples des autres pays du monde ne
doivent plus avoir peur de nous les
allemands ont changé dans beaucoup de
domaines
ils ont appris à respecter ceux qui
vivent dans la liberté est ici
particulièrement rencontre avec gregor
ghisi le nouveau chef du pc est allemand
il prêche pour que l'unité européenne
soit réalisée avant que ne tombent les
frontières entre les deux allemagnes
sans quoi il y as danger des antennes
nous savons que le président mitterrand
attend aussi de sa visite en rd à la
construction d'un ordre de pays
européens et que leipzig a aussi une
signification profonde au centre de
l'europe grosse bouteille d'eau les
accords bilatéraux qui seront signés ici
au conseil d'état permettront donc à la
rda de s'appuyer sur l'europe pour une
future confédération entre les deux
allemagnes situation bloquée dans le
conflit des nmpp il n'y aura donc pas de
journaux pour le septième jour
consécutif dans les kiosques demain les
éditeurs de la presse parisienne
s'apprête à mettre en place un service
de remplacement pour la distribution je
vous rappelle que les nmpp ont le
monopole de la distribution des journaux
parisiens et qu'une grève paralyse donc
l'acheminement dans toute la france le
point sur ce conflit véronique gallium
puisque les journaux ne vont plus au
kiosque la rue viens tu as eu cet après
midi en plein après-midi de faerie les
salariés de libération brader leurs
quotidiens l'as et devoirs s'empiler
dans leurs locaux d'effeuiller
stérilement composé comme les 110
quotidien et 490 publications étrangères
d'ordinaire distribués par les nmpp
libération n'est plus en kiosques depuis
une semaine
motif la grève des syndicalistes cgt des
nouvelles messageries de la presse
parisienne
on croyait que les négociations
achoppaient sur le plan des salaires il
n'en est rien la direction accepte
depuis cette nuit de lâcher 6000 francs
de primes à ses salariés mais 6000
francs sous conditions
nous au billère et ben ce qu'on peut
vous proposer
c'est un accord pour besoins qui ne peut
pas être un accord global de
modernisation qui peut être une
adaptation en 1990 1991
du trop court terme pour les salariés
cgt qui craignent le spectre des
licenciements la prime louis la
modernisation oui également mais avec
une redéfinition des tâches et la
promesse d'investissement dialogue
bloqué les patrons de presse ont
sérieusement à court circuiter les nmpp
nous avons décidé de créer un réseau de
distribution de secours
ainsi samedi solution de secours puisque
aussi bien les nappes et ne peuvent pas
remplir leur office totalement brisé un
monopole de la distribution qui existe
depuis plus de 40 ans la voix des
patrons de presse restent bien étroite
mais depuis une semaine 36 mille points
de vente ne sont plus approvisionnées
les journaux se font mais ne se vendent
pas les plus petits titre flirte
aujourd'hui avec la faillite
la lutte contre le travail clandestin à
elle sera renforcée ainsi en ont décidé
les députés qui ont voté un amendement
en ce sens cette nuit c'est le travail
clandestin est particulièrement pratique
et dans des secteurs comme l'habillement
et le bâtiment alors pratiquement
comment ça se passait bien fait ce
qu'ont voulu savoir
jean pierre métivier et jean corneille
reportage clandestin
là sous ce porche deux inspecteurs du
travail qui s'apprête à effectuer un
contrôle dans des entreprises de
confection
voici ce que provoque leur arrivée tous
ceux qui sont payés de la main à la main
qui ne sont pas sur les registres de
l'employeur vont attendre que le
contrôle se passe derrière le porge
plusieurs entreprises déclaré un petit
noyau d'employés stable nous sommes loin
du sentier dans un autre arrondissement
populaire de paris
en une nuit si on peut faire face à des
commandes énorme des centaines de pièces
en travaillant 15 heures s'il le faut on
embauche au noir pour quelques temps
actuellement c'est la période creuse
le travail ne reprendra qu'en janvier
avec la collection de printemps
le sentier s'est déplacé en banlieue par
exemple dans ses tours on travaille à
domicile en famille payé à la pièce
c'est un désaccord sur les contrats
c'est bien marqué sur la contre
indication
la grange j'aurais fait une réflexion
m'a dit me faut bien pour moi nous on a
des enfants donc ça je comprends mais il
faudrait quand même qu'ils respectent
certaines heures parce que ça travaille
aussi bien samedi que dimanche que les
jours de ces rustres explique on était
trois francs ils sauvegardent taille et
même les jours fériés
après l'univers des tâcherons celui des
donneurs d'ordre les marques de
prêt-à-porter féminin elle se contente
d'imposer leur étiquette
ils jouent les ponce pilate mais elle ne
cause pas ne pas savoir dans une grosse
commande de pantalon vous avez le
pantalon qui va être acheté à 25 francs
aux façonniers le façonnier lui-même il
a un prix de revient de la manoeuvre
son prix de revient de la main d'oeuvre
pour produire un pantalon il faut une
heure une heure charges sociales
comprises
c'est au moins 45 francs 25 francs d'un
côté 45 francs de l'autre il faut
forcément du travail clandestin pour
arriver à tenir les 25 francs certains
sites le sentier comme un modèle de
souplesse économique
d'autres souhaitent un coup de pied dans
la fourmilière les inspecteurs du
travail qui participaient aux opérations
de répression ou même les forces de
l'ordre le savent les mêmes ateliers
conte a dit souvent se reconstituer deux
jours après trois jours après tellement
la pression sur les du marché forte
ou alors on dit que la france cesse
d'être le lieu où on fabrique des
industries made
mais en fait on ne l'a pas fait et on
n'est pas près de le faire parce que ce
serait une grande partie des emplois
productifs de paris qui disparaîtraient
les créateurs le tissu des boutiques etc
depuis hier la police a obtenu sous
contrôle du juge de pouvoir accéder plus
facilement à sédhiou privés entreprises
ou appartement où l'on pratique le
travail non déclaré au regard des enjeux
économiques
il ya peu de chances que ce soit le
remède miracle deux gendarmes emporté et
tué par une avalanche
aujourd'hui c'est dans le massif de
l'oisans cela s'est passé au col de la
temple à 2900 mètres d'altitude
ces gendarmes participer à des
recherches pour retrouver donc des
alpinistes égarés alors attention si
vous pratiquer l'alpinisme en ce moment
la montagne est dangereuse en raison des
conditions météo tout de suite d'autres
informations avec anne consigny
le juge t-il sans forcément dessaisi du
dossier de jacques gosso maire de toul
inculpé dans la sphère des fausses
factures de nancy un élu est inculpé la
cour de cassation a donc confié le
dossier à la chambre d'accusation
il refera sans doute appel aux jupes
style et doyer de françois mitterrand en
faveur des ostréiculteurs du bassin de
thau leurs huîtres sont interdites à la
vente ce matin au conseil des ministres
le président a demandé que des mesures
compensatoires soient prises avant noël
cet avis les ostréiculteurs qui
bloquaient la nationale 113 1 dès son
lever leur barrage ci a deux défauts de
fonctionnement de l'airbus a320 mais
manque de vigilance et de préparation au
vol
principale conclusion du rapport
définitif de la commission d' enquête
sur l'accident d'habsheim trois morts
parmi les passagers en juin 88 lors d'un
vol de démonstration
le pilote allait lui mis en cause le
fonctionnement de l'appareil
renforcement aujourd'hui des mesures de
sécurité en vigueur dans les aéroports
contrôle de foule et bagages de soute
surtout des bagages en correspondance et
fouille manuelle et bagages à main les
effectifs des joies noter que renforcer
50 crs affectés à roissy et orly 25
autres à l'aéroport de lyon satolas
à la bourse de paris après cinq séances
consécutives de baisse l'a dit cette
carence est en hausse importante euros
le dollar s'échange à 596 fils au cours
officiel tout de suite les toutes
dernières informations sur
l'intervention américaine au panama en
direct et en duplex avec nous jacquat
bouchard à washington jacques quel
nouvel os
vous avez quel dernières nouvelles bien
écouté du les derniers témoignages font
état d'une résistance assez assez vive
au moins dans certains secteurs certains
secteurs de la ville
il s'agit plus que de poche de
résistance on disait tout à l'heure par
exemple qu'on entendait très nettement
le départ des pièces d'artillerie alors
que en début de matinée la résistance
avait semblé un petit peu faiblir après
avoir été déjà très très forte au cours
de la nuit donc en fait
on reconnaît au pentagone du côté
américain au ministère de la défense
américain que la résistance est plus
forte que ce qu'on escomptait en tout
cas cette intervention au panama ne sera
pas une promenade de santé et n'a rien
de commun par exemple avec ce qui
s'était passé en 1983 lors de l'invasion
de la grenade alors jacques est ce que
l'âme l'opinion américaine ne commence
pas à trouver que cette opération éclair
traîne un peu écoutés dans l'opinion
américaine est massivement si je peux
dire derrière son président je vous
signale à titre tout à fait anecdotique
que une chaîne de télévision à ses
livres et un sondage express 92% des
réponse était oui à l'intervention bien
sûr les américains avec une vision très
négative de monsieur noriega c'est un
dictateur un trafiquant de drogue
il a humilié l'amérique il a lui-même
pris l'initiative la semaine dernière de
dire qu'il était en état de guerre avec
les états unis
un officier américain a été tué une
femme américaine a été molesté
sexuellement l'image de noriega était
très très négatives dans l'opinion
américaine
merci jacques nous vous retrouvons dans
notre édition lockerbie
la catastrophe de l'avion qui a explosé
en vol au-dessus de l'ecosse c'était il
ya un an juste 270 morts vous en
souvenez certainement et une enquête qui
se poursuit sans relâche mais pour
l'instant les enquêteurs livre assez peu
des résultats de leurs recherches ils
sont très discrets on peut tout de même
reconstitué les choses à peu près comme
elles se sont passées
philippe harrouard à londres personne
n'a oublié ces images les morceaux du
boeing éparpillés sur des dizaines de
kilomètres
un an après l'explosion voici le boeing
reconstituer 85% des morceaux ont été
retrouvé un fragment minuscule d'un
circuit électrique fiché dans ce
container à bagages a permis de
découvrir qu'une bombe dissimulée dans
un transistor était à l'origine de la
catastrophe
pour savoir où était située la valise
contenant le transistor
le fbi a fait exploser plusieurs bovine
destinées à la casse on sait maintenant
qu'elle était dans le conteneur des
bagages enregistrés à francfort
ou en transit dans cet aéroport pour
savoir qui a placé la bombe
les enquêteurs se sont intéressés aux
événements de francfort deux mois avant
l'attentât
un raid dans cet appartement a permis de
découvrir trois transistors piéger et
surtout d'arrêter 17 personnes dont
alphaize dalle kamoni le représentant du
groupe palestinien d'armes et djibril et
marouane cris chatte le faiseur de bon
qui sera d'ailleurs relâchés enfin un
certain mograbi va conduire les
enquêteurs sur la piste d'abu talent
un palestinien vivant en suède est
arrêté en mai dernier pour terrorisme
grâce un morceau de vêtement vendus dans
l'île de malte est trouvé dans la valise
contenant la bombe
les policiers sont persuadés qu abou
tâlib s'est rendu à malte avec un
transistor piégé fabriqués à francfort
par dale kamoni la valise contenant la
radio a été placé sur un avion d'air
malta puis transféré à francfort en
bagage non accompagné sur le brain 103
de la panam abou tâlib est interrogé ce
jeudi par des policiers britanniques en
suède pour l'instant officiellement
aucune inculpation n'était en vue maison
du premier pour l'année prochaine que l'
enquête sera public
c'est dire que des noms seront révélés
et des poursuites engagées
mais pourra-t-on savoir si comme
l'affirment après le britannique c'est
l'iran qui est derrière toute cette
affaire se venger de la destruction de
fond d'airbus par un navire américain
juste avant de partir pour l'allemagne
de l'est le président mitterrand a
participé comme chaque année avec son
épouse à l'arbre de noël de l'elysée 600
enfants dans la vaste salle des fêtes
parmi eux des écoliers de wallis et
futuna
et oui aussi guadeloupe et aussi de la
guadeloupe au programme la bande à
belleville des chimpanzés et le grand
orchestre du splendid
un nouveau film sur les écrans demain
c'est la rencontre de cinq monstres
sacrés moussorsgki modeste de son prénom
qui a écrit un opéra superbe qui
s'appelle boris godounov hausse autres
monstres de l'histoire un cinéaste
monstrueusement dérangeant zylawski qui
s'empare de l'opéra le porte au cinéma
avec dans le rôle-titre ruggero raimondi
gentil monstre au sommet de sa gloire et
rostropovitch le cinquième l'intouchable
pour la musique
résultat un film opéra détonnant et
sachets par parenthèse que ruggero
raimondi sera demain soir l'invité de
jacques chancel dans le grand échiquier
à 20h35 sur antenne 2 mais pour l'heure
voyons la performance de raimondi dans
le film boris godounov
au tempérament artistique volcanique 2
ou là ce qui ne pouvait évidemment pas
se contenter d'une illustration passé et
statique d'un opéra il en pulvérise donc
les conventions nous entraîne dans le
tourbillon de moussan ce qui resserre la
dramaturgie de pouchkine pour en faire
ressortir la modernité
c'est un peuple en mouvement ce sont des
les destins en mouvement il ya autant du
tsar russe que de l'usurpateur qui veut
lui prendre son trône et qui tombe
amoureux d'une princesse polonaise 0
metz j'ai essayé de le re équilibrée
comme ça serait équilibre dans les
grands mouvements de la vie n'est ce pas
mais il n'y a pas particulièrement
véhémence violente provocation contre
roddick mais il ya des petits clins
d'oeil
ainsi les quoique du canard ou les
pulsions érotiques frénétiques ont fait
hurler rostropovitch directeur musical
je comprends irritation de gens qui sont
habitués maintenant à voir le sénat
aucune espèce d'énorme des cerces pas
mais moi je donne l'entrée le plat
principal le vin l'armagnac le fromage
et le dessert l'art au musée ne
l'intéresserait compos
qui pourrait lui reprocher de briser
notre confort et de rendre ainsi un
chef-d'oeuvre plus familier surtout
lorsque le dard est une star ruggero
raimondi y résident
voilà et puisque nous parlons cinéma x à
la période des livres cadeaux et bien je
vous présente celui ci se livre étonnant
dans la collection rams et cinéma ça
s'intitule entre deux sens sur certains
documents sur le cinéma érotique entre
la libération de la censure et
classement des films x entre 73 et 76
une période qui a très bien retracée
françois jouffa voilà il y avait un tir
ce nom il y à un tir très c'est demain
alors il ya évidemment des pronostics
cette prière est bresse 7 à 20 100es du
trot le 13 le 16 le 7 le 18 le 14 le 17
le 9
et puis le 8 vous rendez vous de la
soirée tout de suite la météo avec le
sophie davant à 22h15 l'émission place
publique présenté par claude sérillon
consacré aux handicapés avec la
participation notamment de michel creton
le comédien qui fera le bilan de la
campagne qu'il mène depuis fort
longtemps un bilan qu'il fera un an jour
pour jour après que la loi en faveur des
handicapés et été votée voilà dernière
édition ce sera henri sannier vers 23h30
bonne soirée à demain 20 heures
à